[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef who's
traveled far in her life and career born
in Santiago Chile
Victoria Blamey was a college student
studying history when she changed her
plans and went off to cooking school
that led to jobs in Britain Australia
Spain and then here in New York where
she won acclaim for reviving Chumley's
historic 1920s speakeasy and that led to
her brand new position at one of the
city's most prestigious restaurants this
summer she took over as executive chef
at Gotham Bar and Grille becoming only
the second chef in the venue's 35-year
history chef Victoria Blamey good
morning welcome - what are we about to
eat yeah I'm gonna show you a little bit
of what we're doing in the restaurant
right now so we start with burrata right
here how's that tomato vinaigrette
cherry tomatoes confit tomato and some
cucumbers over there we have our green
salad or petite salad with a sesame
vinaigrette
over there we have the fettuccine was
spaghetti nari with octopus ragu that is
a bit spicy and side of carrots Kyoto
carrots with a dressing of cars actually
reduction and we have our steak beets
and onions and fantastic beverage oh yes
you're missing that a pisco sour from
Chile by the way this idea of being just
the second chef in a 35-year history of
a restaurant what does that mean to you
I quite didn't get at the beginning that
it was such a big deal to be really
honest room I mean because of the years
and then and then every week it just you
know it kind of became a little bit more
of a oh I understand it's really you
know a restaurant to be open 35 is very
unusual yeah so I think that's pretty
amazing to have any situation like that
how's it going it's going it's going
great you know I think actually better
than I thought him I mean you know we
were understaffed at one point but we're
doing great the team is really strong
what's the timeframe what's the window
like how long do you think it takes to
execute your vision I mean I don't know
I think shifts up perfectionist so
that's my only like a three key question
but you know I think we every day gets
better so that's what I love identity
strong no in this this restaurant had a
lot
you know American cuisine you some say
you blew up the menu so to speak huh how
important was that well it was important
to just have many different cuisines
represented in my brain you know
sometimes I don't it's difficult to
explain my cuisine because people want
to box you in like it's on the end right
or you know some kind of Asian food or
if not if it's Latino food but you know
I've worked in so many different places
and those give you you know gives you
experience and then informs you so for
me to express that and the menu was very
diverse what is it when you did some of
this at Chumley's also this is turning
things up on the upon their head what is
it that you want somebody to get out of
a dining experience when you're the chef
there I just want people to think about
a where things come from you know I love
someone to actually maybe have a memory
of when there were children or someone
just to be completely blown away by
weird different combinations you know
about cooking yeah your childhood I'm
not so much how you became vegetarian
which I did with us thinking right here
you say it changed your life yeah I mean
my mom was really worried at the time so
she gave me also cooking books so
everything's been by a book you know and
I just thought it was more for being a
rebel than having really you know
ambition of like oh poor cow and I
wanted to be that kind of way of like
you know caring about the animals I do
but it was just more like I just want to
do something completely different and I
shouldn't be doing so much meat and then
I just talk all of a sudden and then
continue to do that in South America
it's you know weird just a little bit
completely different has worked for you
I'll have you sign the dish sure if you
could have this meal with anyone past or
present who would it be
oh my mom for sure is the best thank you
so much thank you guys if you want more
on chef Victoria Blamey you can go to
our website at CBS this morning calm